le loup-garou sérieux MIOM mi animal le
loup-garou peuple les romans les comics
les clips de Michael Jackson les films
et les forêts sombres les expper
bataille sur l'origine de la légende
mais si un médecin pouvait examiner un
loup-garou sans danger genre un
loup-garou végan par exemple il lui
diagnostiquerait sans doute une
hypertricose doublé d'une licantthropie
clinique l'hypertricot c'est un
développement excessif des poils plus ou
moins localisé ça peut ressembler à ça
mais ça peut aller un peu plus loin
voire beaucoup plus loin voilà ça
c'était pour le visuel pour le
comportement maintenant la lcantropique
lig c'est tout simplement une maladie
psychiatrique qui consiste à se prendre
pour un loup et donc à reproduire les
comportements de la bête marcher à
quatre pattes pousser des hurlements et
mordre et pour la pleine lune ça c'est
juste du folklore par contre